[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG:
So Trevor, I keep
hearing all about this machine
learning stuff, but a lot of it
goes over my head.
TREVOR HILLIS: I used
to think that, too.
But it turns out, you can get
started with it pretty easily.
In fact, I was able to
build a machine learning
model in just a few minutes.
STEPHANIE WONG:
And all you needed
was a highly-trained
data scientist, right?
TREVOR HILLIS: Nope.
Just some data and BigQuery.
Here, let me show you how.
Let's get started.
The first step in any email
problem is gathering data.
So I'm going to use publicly
available data on city bike
share usage and weather
in Austin, Texas.
I'm going to try and predict
how the weather in Austin
affects the daily
trips per bike,
which the city could use to
make decisions about pricing
of insurance for those bikes
or how many bikes to leave out
on a rainy day.
I started in the
BigQuery web console
and used the Create Model
command to name and train
my model.
I specified that this is
a linear regression model
and that my input column,
or the value that I'm
going to be predicting,
is trips per bike.
Next I use standard SQL to
choose the feature columns
or model inputs that
are going to be used
to predict trips per bike--
in this case, temperature
and precipitation data.
I then trained my model,
which will all happen
in just about 30 seconds.
While the model
is training, let's
get our model ready
to be evaluated.
This is how you'll find
out important stats
about your model, like how
useful it is for predictions
and what your average error is.
Once the model is
trained, you can
click the model in
your BQ data set, which
will include information
on the training stats,
like the number of
iterations your model ran
and what your training loss
was and your learn rate.
To evaluate our model, we
run the ML.EVALUATE command,
referencing the name of the
model we want to evaluate,
then selecting the
same feature columns
we used to train our
model in our first query.
Two columns to pay close
attention to are r-squared
score and mean squared error.
You typically want an
r-squared score closer to 1.
So there's a lot of room for
improvement in this model.
There's a great article
in the description
that talks more about
how to interpret
the results for a model.
But let's go ahead and use our
model to make a prediction.
The PREDICT command
is almost identical
to our ML.EVALUATE
command, except we're
going to select a new column
for our predicted values
at the beginning of the query.
And specify the ML.PREDICT
command, and voila,
we have some predictions.
STEPHANIE WONG: So there's still
a lot that I don't quite get.
But I feel like I could
start using this today.
TREVOR HILLIS: The details
can be pretty complicated.
But this is a great way
to get started making
predictions and learning more.
STEPHANIE WONG: Don't
forget to like, comment,
and subscribe for more great
Google Cloud Platform content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]